vous aviez raconté avoir privé un enfant
d'un self ya un soir de défaite en ligue
des champions et sept enfants c'était
qu'il y adapter cette enfance le killian
qu'on connaît tous c'était vraiment de
killian que vous connaissez tous parce
que
c'est un soir de match de ligue des
champions ce soir de défaite et
d'élimination ce qu'on avait fait un
partout
nous sommes éliminés et je suis très
très très remonté
on
peut le dire bon il ya des enfants et
donc on fait attention maintenant c'est
c1
ce pauvre petit qui était qui étaient là
au mauvais moment où un moment où
j'étais encore ému parle pas par la
performance de l'arbitré et une autre
non qualification
je le jure je ne voyais mal faire une
photo sourire ça l'est peut être
naturelle et cusiter danse et encore on
est encore un peu trop une repas chaud
donc bien sûr que j'ai j'ai eu beaucoup
de regrets mais j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer sa maman est sûre sur un vol
et on en a parlé et m'a dit ne vous
inquiétez pas ça lui arrive aussi donc
ça m'a un peu apaisé parce que c'est
quelqu'un que j'adore et puis c'est une
belle personne est il en train de
devenir
plus fort même que kylie acquis à 2,3
encore bon alors voilà ça y est le
dossier est classé l'affairé classée en
garde bien sûr